welcome back to las vegas now the
halloween edition now halloween makeup
as you can see it can be scary
especially when you have to do it
yourself so we are checking back in with
our resident makeup artist for the day
eric of the michael boyce salon to show
us another easy diy look for this
weekend but before we go there let's
start with jennifer with the sterling
club she's going to tell us you know how
we can celebrate halloween at the club
yes so we have a full weekend with
starting tonight with the
rod stewart tribute tonight supper club
and dancing and then going into our
rutgers ball for saturday so that's
going to be a huge party and then into
our lethal libation on sunday which is a
murder mystery dinner
type of thing it'll be a lot of fun so
if they're looking for a place to go
that's the place
and now we'll have your looks set for
you when you go to the sterling cup to
celebrate so eric let's talk about the
second look we got today okay
you are in a bit of a time stream um
perfect thing to do
that is you just peel them off we have
them there at the salon okay um and then
you put again eyelash glue of course and
then we are going to finish her up with
a little bit of glitter
um with eyelash glue and how long did it
take to apply those
um probably about two minutes wow easy
and then
you just do a little bit of glue
and then you get your glitter
yeah so this is this is eyelash glue
that's something you should probably
have in your bathroom already so that
makes it so easy any uh craft store
i love that so who what is she can we
make some guesses i'm thinking
unicorn or
she is an ice cream ice queen i like
that that's cute and you can obviously
get dressed up with a cute blue dress or
white dress make it sexy make it sexy
but also make it creative and express
yourself because that is a part of the
rules here right for halloween when
you're doing your own makeup
give everybody your second tip
the first tip was there are no rules for
applying makeup what's the second the
second tip is carry your eyelash glue in
your purse
that's a good one so how can people get
more information on